- We have our ice cream truck,
and I always say that's
our ace in the hole.
We have two ice cream trucks now,
and I always joke, I said,
If you told me 37 years ago,
coming on this job, that
our officers would enjoy
riding around in full uniform,
in an ice cream truck,
I'd say you're crazy.
But, that's the type of
policeing that we are now.
I only bring that up,
because Chelsea Byankays,
who's a great partner, he's
buying ice cream truck now.
So, like, St. Louis has
bought an ice cream truck.
So everyone's buying ice cream trucks now
because what a better way
to interact with young kids.
Especially after, heaven
forbid, I remember
in Washington Park off
of one of the boulevards,
we had a young kid shot
and people were fearful
to go back and the next
day we were down there
giving out hoodsies.
So that's become a key
component of who we are.